herr kubicki wenn die stimmung nochmals
schlechter wird wir haben in den
niederlanden sogar krawalle locker und
krawalle gesehen das war zwar eine ganz
seltsame mischung von menschen wieder
auf der straße war auch viele hooligans
die diese stimmung ausgenutzt haben und
trotzdem war der ausgangspunkt eben
diese depression im zuge des lok downs
wir sehen im moment noch geht umfragen
zufolge eine relativ breite
unterstützung für die lok down maßnahmen
eine mehrheit kann man sich da in
sicherheit wiegen oder muss man sagen
mensch wenn 30 über 30 prozent
bundesweit mittlerweile tief frustriert
sind und zunehmend wütend sind darüber
wie die entscheidungen getroffen werden
und was für entscheidungen getroffen
werden dass das ja gefährlich wird die
gefahr sehe ich auch weil mittlerweile
die keine option die wir ja wirklich gut
umschlägt nach denen er lauterbach der
kretschmann erklärt haben ostern werde
es keinen urlaub bekommen und auf
stetiges im urlaubsland sie müssen sich
mal anschauen wie die hoteliers und die
gastronomen hier darauf reagieren und
zwar deshalb weil sie sagen wir uns ist
erklärt worden jetzt vielleicht 35 sind
mittelmaß oder das später vielleicht
haben soll wieder geöffnet werden jetzt
wird uns aber gleichzeitig gesagt in
ostern ist sechs wochen später als im
märz
er wird auch alles wieder zu sein wird
es keine reisen geben es gibt gar keine
perspektive und diese wut die
manifestiert sich die wird irgendwann
umschlagen auch in gewalttätigkeiten das
befürchte ich auch vor allem 2001
hinweist und der ministerpräsident eines
landes das infektionsschutzgesetz hat
die inzidenz zahl 35 und 50 bewusst
genannt beide zahlen bewusst im lande
zwar deshalb weil das eskalationsstufe
sind von denen ab sie grundrechts
beschränkende maßnahmen ergreifen ab 35
milde maßnahmen ab 50 sehr schwere
maßnahmen im umkehrschluss
unterschreiten sie die 50 sind maßnahmen
nicht mehr verhältnismäßig wenn sich die
beispiel 13 noch anwenden wollen sie
müssen also darauf reagieren weil die
rechtsprechung wird ihnen das um die
ohren hauen
vor allem mit der argumentation die sie
gewählt haben kommen wir aus dem locker
und nie wieder raus weil wir auch bei 35
nicht wissen ob die nächste mutation die
vielleicht auch wieder ihr fell die
infektiöse ist la palma hat recht wir
wissen momentan dass die britische
mutation keine schwereren verläufen und
nicht mehr todesfälle verursacht als die
anderen und wenn es uns gelingt in den
alten und pflegeheim endlich der
versorgung zu tragen
wenn wir dort infiziert entweder durch
tests durch impfungen wenn wir die über
80 jährigen schützen dann kann es die
instituts relativ egal sein weil wir
genau wissen dass bei den unter
50-jährigen hier kaum schwerer verläufe
tot ist dann auch immer welche aber
äußerst wenig das tier damit vernünftig
umgehen können insofern denken sie noch
mal drüber nach daher günther zu recht
gesagt wir werden einen stufenplan
aufbauen müssen weil wir nicht alles
zulassen können wir 37 sind ja genau
deshalb herr kubicki ist ja auch nicht
nichts entschieden worden wir haben
jetzt entschieden dass wir erste
schritte machen der lockerung vor allem
bei den grundschulen und in der kita
betreuung und wir haben entschieden dass
etwas was nicht milch aber die meisten
menschen dann doch berührt nämlich dass
es am ersten märz wieder möglich sein
soll
die friseure zu öffnen natürlich mit
hygiene konzepten und allen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die die möglich sind
das heißt es ist ja nicht entschieden
worden wir machen jetzt nicht sondern
wir haben einfach gesagt für diese stufe
zwischen 50 und 35 dürfen wir jetzt
nicht unvorsichtig sein weil wir eben
sehr schnell hinterher nicht mehr über
35 oder 50 sprechen sondern weil wir
eben sehr schnell wieder richtung 100
gehen können und wir haben in
deutschland erlebt im november im
dezember wie schnell wir nicht nur bei
110 sondern bei 200 und wer mittlerweile
65 1000 tote in deutschland und ich kann
nur allen empfehlen einmal mit jemandem
zu sprechen der auf einer
intensivstation arbeitet oder der
einfach beschreiben kann
wie das wie die wie das
gesundheitssystem unter volllast ja ich
nehme an dass das wieder jeder von den
vieren gemacht hat dass das selbst noch
die haut sein anderssein palma sowieso
getan hat frauke und frauchen dass
minister zuständig gewesen wäre
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren